今年度到一句價值10萬的話,其實很早之前就知道,今天感觸特別深,還是15
這句話來自保羅雄斯,就是羅冰漢基金會的創始人,在前這位書裡,他說了這麼一話,他是給一個把學做演講的時候,他說
現在就能得到價值10萬美元的一堂課,只需要記住我,說到2.9個我了,你一定要跟人上最重要的大趨勢
美國兩個最後前的人,一個是必要該死,一個是8倍特,這個必要該死什麼有錢的,感傷了一個大的趨勢
PC時代,讓他長期持有自己創了一個壓公司,為軟的股票,張了8百多位
白貝特的話,就是我一要買為大的公司,對於是為大的公司長期持有
很多年前,大概有10年,差不多有10年了,我對一輩好朋友,在小米,那個時候小米還沒有名了,但是雷雲老師很有名了,內部經常做分享
我們也不是很經常見面,有一次見面的時候就問他說,那麼分享著你感覺最深的是什麼,他說是命
後來這個命雷雲老師做演講的時候說了,站在封口上,出鬥能飛,這句話並沒有引起足夠的總是
現在要我們重新的理解一下長期持有,或者你認為就堅持,我再又趕越上一直堅持
所謂的長期持有,不是你買的時候就一直拿著,首先你的方的樣式會大趨勢,方的樣式會不會正確的,就你的眼光不能太下展,比如說你頭子的時候,你不能從看那個分石土,你不能從看那個日寫
放長遠一點,看看周信,看看這個月寫,看看三年五年
那你做工作的時候也是,你不能指定的說,我這個月那種東西,我今年的那麼多東西,你要看看你這件事情是不是有其類的,對你未來發展是不是有幫助
所以我們在看一些頭子,頭子不只是把前範,還有時間放在那,對不對,方向一定是正確,如果方向不正確所謂的長期持有所謂的努力
所謂的堅持,不一定能說話好的結果